and this this was one take that's it you
can really only do one take
every day um we just have an incredible
producing team
organizing everything killing everyone
off camera
[Music]
well look at that image right there i
mean what doesn't draw you to it
you know there's uh i love the horizon
you know i i just uh i don't know why
but
i just love it this was filmed in
courtside arizona
and a place that i actually haven't been
before until this film
and i learned about of course i saw
jessica bruder's book
and i drove to the actual event the
actual rtr
uh six months prior we started shooting
and there were 10 000 people
there you know and and the one we
created
was the rtr that was 10 years ago so
there's only 50 people there
and when we shot it the real one was
happening at the same time
so it's a very interesting comparison
i can't imagine what you're going
through the
loss of your husband and the loss of
your whole town
and friends and village and that kind of
kind of loss is never easy
and i wish i had an easy answer for you
but
i think you've come to the right place
to find an answer i think that
i think connecting to nature and and
to a real true community and tribe will
make all the difference
for you i hope so well in this moment
fern had just left where she's from
which is northern nevada
in the cold landscape to the desert
in corset arizona where there's a
gathering
of nomads and van dwellers called the
rapper trump rendezvous the rtr
bob wales swanky and linda may three of
our main supporting roles
are from jessica butler's book she has
gotten to know them and follow them for
years
[Music]
we did a lot of magikarp landscape shots
whenever we could
knowing that it would help time passing
the whole shoot is planned that way it's
based on time of day and seasons
and then we don't really start shooting
until lunch time until after lunch time
because we want to shoot into the
evening and
we're really challenging ourselves like
we're using the last
30 minutes to 45 minutes to shoot some
of the dialogue scenes
and sometimes we would shoot a scene
in two days so then we can have
consistent light
if you look at where that sun is right
if this sounds any higher
you would have you would have blow
things up right
the sky wouldn't be the same if it's any
lower you would
lose details on what's what's in front
of it and
the shot continues until the atv comes
in as well
and friend's reaction first reaction
that moment she shook her head and
laughed
it's genuine because friend thought that
was an accident
the atv coming but though it was it was
planned
so so we're very proud of that shot that
happened
[Music]
be back soon
the score is simple um and
you know isn't too hopeful you know it
isn't saying like oh everything is going
to be just fine with this community
um it it gives a feeling of a sunset
you know i think and and um it really is
just her for the first time in the film
she goes i can stand still for a second
and it's gonna be okay
just for a brief moment until everybody
leave and you feel that way a lot when
you're on the road
you make that connection with both the
land and the people
and then a few days later a couple weeks
later everyone leave
so you're constantly feeling this gain
and loss and gain and loss
and as a result you actually have a
quite healthy relationship with how
transient everything is
[Music]
you know i love those video games it's
not like shooting
or or zombies coming at me i like the
kind of video games where you just walk
through beautiful landscapes and
collecting wood and
you know like the game the trail um so
we talked a lot about video
games and and then how immersive it is
and to just follow a character and
walking through this space and the
camera drifts and and there's a lot to
discover in the frame
so that's the conception of this shot
and rdp is really good at calculating
because he's done this a few times now
the exact time of day where the sun is
in the right place
and we're backlighting the character and
and
this this was one take that's it you can
really only do one take
every day um we just have an incredible
producing team
organizing everything cueing everyone
off camera
and then our incredible sound design
team just rebuild the entire
soundscape so you're not only
watching but you're also hearing things
the sound of the tire of the bicycle you
hear
before you arrive because your years are
actually
getting much sharper when you're out
there without all the sitting noises
i think on my line i fell in love with
the with the ronin gimbal
which is what we shot this uh this um
the movie was so
breaks out of time you know people just
give up on it and then the ronin is
amazing and then they haven't really
used it
in big movies yet by the time i went on
to eternals there's very few people
even know how to use it um and and we
did we shot the eternals
uh ninety 90 on the ronin with with the
same camera
[Music]
you